the jurgen experience it's called
the man who shot hitler and then bigfoot
and i saw it recently it's a sam elliott
movie it says
whoa okay actually wow it is an
interesting movie and he can't get each
other
i enjoyed it i watched it on a flight
and i downloaded it because i was like
what is this
right what is the man who shot hitler
and then bigfoot but i'm a big sam
elliott fan
and it got good so uh i said okay
i'll give it a shot it's really
interesting okay
i mean he i mean it's they're not hiding
it
he shot bigfoot and then hitler the man
who killed hitler and then bigfoot
when did this come out i don't know and
he can't get hiv
the thing was that he had a very
specific gene
they brought him back to service because
after he'd killed hitler he's an older
man
but he had a very specific gene that
made him immune
to this disease that bigfoot had and
that bigfoot
was sick and that his virus was killing
all the wildlife that was anywhere near
him and there was a dead zone
around bigfoot they were tracking him
and they had to have someone go in there
and kill bigfoot
so they bring in sam elliott when he's
like 70 years old
spoiler alert to go in and kill bigfoot
it's [ __ ] cool
i enjoyed it man i mean it's not
it's not you know 2001 a space odyssey
but it's a [ __ ] cool movie
it's a definitely a b movie i mean
is that bigfoot where this little shadow
thing no they see them pretty up close
i mean maybe they don't show it in the
preview but it's pretty up close
it's gnarly that's it i don't want to
say too much
yeah don't yeah completely much but he
does kill hitler
yeah well killed hitler and then and
then bigfoot it says it in the title
people really want to kill hitler that's
like a thing that movies are doing huh
yeah
yeah you know i was watching a video of
uh hitler tweaking
hitler's on speed you know he did a lot
of speed yeah
he's at the 1936 olympics and he's
sitting in the audience like this
like tweeting it was like an actual like
footage of actual footage
apparently somebody had taken it and
sped it up
and uh made it uh unrealistic
just to show like make it look like he's
really really really tweaking yeah
and then um it was hard to find
for some people to find the actual speed
footage
but this is this is the actual speed
footage they believe
um so he's just rocking back and forth
tweaking wow he does have crackhead
energy that's amazing 100
tweaking so i mean there's no way you
rock like that from that weekend
he's like fidgety too where's his left
hand what is happening there
he's touching he's got a little glove
his left hand's got a glove and he's
rubbing a gun on his dick
go back replay please look at this
how weird is that man how weird is it to
see that guy go full screen
so he jerks off with his gun we can he
masturbates in a way
he's literally tight i'm just joking
about a gun i don't think really a gun
but he's definitely got his hand on his
dick
he's like a a guy who's freaking out
it might might as well be a meth head
right let me see how they let this guy
like
i mean look at him he's got something
he's touching his dick with
see it yeah exactly yeah i mean you said
gun
it looks like his hands curled over it
does like he's got something in his hand
dude he's rubbing something on his
pecker do you have a cane
yeah oh he's rubbing his cam maybe he's
holding
yeah he's but look go go towards the end
of it and we'll pause when you can see
the hand
right next to his dick it's so weird
it is moving now watch watch when you
see his hand
good get that bar out of the bottom
there it is over the pants hand job that
he's giving himself
look he's got something in his hand and
that something in his hand is in between
his legs
you said kane i mean you might be wrong
you said i mean you were joking about
the gun but i mean it could be it could
be a cane
it could be a ruger it might be a gun i
think it looks more like cane now that
i'm looking at